la carta perché non ci sarà più la carta
perché io ora sono costretto avere degli
appunti perché ho qualche dato è un paio
di occhiali perché non ci vedo sono
sicuro del fra dieci anni i dati cela
però negli occhiali quindi perlomeno
farò una cosa sola mi metterò gli
occhiali vetro e vetro passare i dati
nei miei occhiali 21 dicembre 2012
che cosa accadrà in realtà non lo
sappiamo possiamo avere qualche speranza
legittimamente magari cala un po lo
spread riparte l'economia i mercati si
cominciano a rigirare e forse potranno
potremmo avere un abbassamento delle
tasse o al limite che le paghino tutti
vediamo queste sono speranze ma certo
non lo sappiamo
voi sapete che nel calendario nel
calendario maya in realtà finisce l'era
dell'oro
un'era dell'oro è già finita sicuramente
quella del giornalismo il giornalismo
sta vivendo dentro la crisi di cui oggi
hanno parlato persone delle persone che
mi hanno preceduto sta vivendo una sua
propria crisi strutturale all'interno
della crisi generale che ha colpito
l'economia le tante loro del giornalismo
a un presupposto cioè l'invenzione della
stampa metà del quattrocento gutenberg
inventa la stampa a caratteri mobili
si comincia a stampare ci vogliano
ancora qualche centinaia d'anni prima
che nasca il giornalismo il giornalismo
nasce negli stati uniti nel 1830 perché
un editore illuminato decide di
abbassare drasticamente il costo del
denaro si chiama penny press questo fan
la formula questa formula e cosa fa
crea il primo mass media della storia
perché prima i giornali se lo leggevano
l'elite non è che le leggeva il popolo
leggeva chiunque circolavano pochissimi
giornali costavano molto e li leggevano
in pochi questo editore a un certo punto
all'intuizione mette il giornale o un
penny comincia avere una grande
circolazione e diventa un prodotto
interessante per gli inserzionisti cioè
per coloro che fanno pubblicità si crea
questo questa formula questo triangolo
editore pubblico inserzionista che per
200 anni ha dato le i ricavi le risorse
per il giornalismo moderno le cose sono
cominciate andare molto male verso la
fine del
decennio scorso intorno al 2008 vi do
alcuni dati di oggi che sono
impressionanti nel primo semestre di
quest'anno negli stati uniti i giornali
americani hanno hanno perso come quote
di pubblicità circa 800 milioni di
dollari
e vero c'è il digitale dall'altra parte
sappiamo tutti che ci stiamo spostando
sul digitale
bene il digitale ha guadagnato in più
rispetto all'anno precedente in quel
semestre nello stesso semestre 32
milioni di dollari
voi capite che i conti non tornano cioè
per ogni 25 dollari che una copia
stampata aperte
l'online e guadagna 1 secondo le
previsioni del center for digital
feature la maggior parte dei giornali
americani avrà cinque anni di vita
quindi non stiamo parlando di futuro
stiamo parlando di presente cinque anni
sono un attimo sapete perché notizia di
paio di settimane fa una settimana fa
che la crisi ha già colpito tanti
giornali importanti ma certo newsweek
nessuno se lo aspettava newsweek ha
annunciato tina brown ha annunciato una
settimana fa il direttore ha annunciato
che newsweek stamperà l'ultima copertina
alla fine di quest'anno il 31 dicembre
quindi mai a qualcosa devono averla
indovinato il 31 dicembre 2012 esce
l'ultimo numero di newsweek
ovviamente il giornale il settimanale
americano proseguirà in digitale verrà
venduto su abbonamento solo in digitale
ma per le cifre che abbiamo detto prima
certo non è più la stessa cosa in italia
non è che stiamo molto molto meglio nel
2000 si vendevano più di 6 milioni di
copie al giorno nel
2011 quindi circa dieci anni dopo le
copie sono scese a 4,5 milioni al giorno
quindi quattro milioni e mezzo l'anno
scorso quest'anno nel primo trimestre
secondo le proiezioni della fieg siamo
scesi sotto la soglia dei 4 milioni cioè
pensate
rispetto all'anno scorso del primo
trimestre siamo già a 3,8 milioni quindi
è evidente che c'è una accelerazione
impressionante di circolazione dei
giornali allora ho detto mi sono messo
un po a pensare a quello che potrebbe
succedere e mi sono ispirato sono andate
a guardare cosa è successo quando kuten
berg ha inventato la stampa a caratteri
mobili che cos'era la stampa a caratteri
mobili processo industriale è l'embrione
di un primo processo industriale
velocità perché certamente ha
velocizzato il processo di diffusione
della del sapere della cultura
la possibilità di stampare più copie
soprattutto di far circolare più copie
e tutto questo con un costo molto minore
di quello che si sosteneva prima per
produrre una singola copia
tenete presente che un amanuense per
copiare una bibbia ci metteva circa un
anno e non lavorava da solo se non ce ne
metteva di più quindi voi capite che
questo processo di industrializzazione
era estremamente più economico rispetto
agli amanuensi che infatti di lì a poco
sono morti
l'invenzione di cute per ha creato un
processo industriale che ha funzionato
alla meraviglia per 500 anni
poi però nel 2000 scusate nel 1991 un
certo tim berners lee ha messo a punto
un qualcosa che forse è un po più
economico è un po più veloce della
stampa il web il web
indubbiamente ha contribuito a
velocizzare ulteriormente i processi di
diffusione del sapere e soprattutto
abbattuto i costi in maniera
impressionante
voi pensate che per fare una televisione
o per fare un giornale ci aveva tanti di
quei soldi che giusto berlusconi poteva
farsi tre televisioni un giornale e più
svariati libri e settimanali ma a una
persona comune non era permesso accedere
all'informazione col web questo come
dire questa posizione di elite
dell'editore si è indebolita oggi una
persona che ha buone idee e ha voglia
può riuscire a diventare se non altro un
editore di se stesso di un gruppo di
persone
e allora la domanda che mi sono posto è
ma il web è incompatibile con la stampa
punto interrogativo dico che è molto
probabile a mio modo di vedere ma poi
vediamo come il punto fondamentale è che
kuten berga ha ucciso probabilmente
sicuramente con la sua invenzione gli
amanuensi ma non ha ucciso il sapere con
l'invenzione di cultura il sapere avuto
una diffusione molto maggiore di quella
che aveva avuto fino ai suoi tempi lo
stesso è avvenuto col web il web
potrebbe uccidere la stampa la carta ma
certamente noi abbiamo più informazione
oggi in un anno che probabilmente il
tutto il secolo passato quindi la nostra
domanda è come viaggerà all'informazione
nei prossimi dieci anni quale saranno il
modo di far veicolare l'informazione
come si trasformerà il lavoro del
giornalista
dico subito che è principalmente un
problema culturale
è un problema culturale perché prima
tutto era molto chiaro no c'erano i
fatti c'erano i giornalisti c'erano i
lettori i lettori che cosa faceva
compravano i giornali su quei
giornalisti raccontavano i fatti gli
piacevano non gli piacevano fatti loro
stavano al loro posto non c'era nessuna
interazione tra il lettore il
giornalista al limite il lettore poteva
decide di non comprare più quel giornale
ma non poteva fare molto di più
negli ultimi dieci anni appunto con il
web è cambiato una cosa fondamentale
sono cambiate le abitudini dei lettori
sono cambiate in maniera radicale tanto
è vero che i lettori oggi sono anche dei
produttori di informazione sicuramente
dei selezionatori di informazione e sono
anche dei distributori di informazione
lo siamo tutti noi con twitter con
facebook con le miconi blog con le mille
attività che abbiamo quotidianamente
twitter per prendere una delle
piattaforme che più si sta mescolando e
sta rivoluzionando il giornalismo che
cos'è tweet e twitter è quello che fino
a ieri sono state l'agenzia di stampa è
un notiziario in tempo reale non ci sono
dubbi su questo abbiamo visto con la
primavera araba
quindi con avvenimenti non come dire non
prevedibili in agenda ma lo vediamo
anche con le cose in agenda le elezioni
americane in questi in questi giorni se
voi ogni volta che c'è un dibattito
qualcosa da te su twitter vedete le
milioni di infor nile milioni di
informazioni che circolano da cittadini
comuni americani che riporta notizie
danno informazioni discutano e così via
la morte di whitney houston è stata data
su twitter perché semplicemente la
figlia della assistente domestica di
whitney houston ha saputo dalla mamma
che era morta nella vasca da bagno e lei
è stata la prima a dire che era morta su
su tweet il ministro ormai il ministro e
maghi e stato nominato su twitter perché
quando monti l'ha chiamato er in aula la
cattolica a milano e gli studenti hanno
risposto di sì è sì mario cece si sa
davvero allora sì che i ragazzi hanno
sentite che hanno fatto prossimo non
sapevano di che cosa
ma erano certi che era il prof uno dei
prossimi ministri quindi è evidente che
ormai il giornalismo è qualcosa di non
più così definito è vero che le persone
non fanno giornalismo anche perché non
campano di quelle devono far altro ma
possano fare atti di giornalismo che in
alcuni casi sono molto migliori quelli
che fanno i giornalisti perché
certamente io da giornalista avesse
avuto in esclusiva la morte di whitney
houston del ministro o la nomina del
ministro sarei stato certamente
felicissimo e sarai con vista
convinta del fatto un buon lavoro quindi
il fatto è che sono cambiate le
abitudini dei lettori e che le abitudini
dei lettori hanno cambiato il mercato
questo è il motivo per cui un certo tipo
di supporto dell'informazione è andato
in crisi
non c'è dubbio che se la stampa vuole
sopravvivere deve imparare a cogliere le
opportunità le opportunità di questo
cambiamento
la domanda non è così semplice è come
trasportare quegli antichi valori che
hanno reso una professione per 200 anni
una professione come traghettarla nel
giornalismo del terzo millennio
allora io appunto se come qua si parla
di te mi è stato chiesto di portare
qualche idea ho buttato giù una sorta di
manifesto in dieci punti
la premessa che è un punto fermo perché
sennò possiamo smettere di parlare non
vale niente la premessa è che il
giornalismo di qualità non è gratis
non è gratis perché costa l'editore
chiunque anche se ci mettiamo insieme
noi vogliamo fare mandare uno in america
1 in sud fare un'inchiesta in africa ci
vogliano i soldi quindi il giornalismo
di qualità le inchieste non sono
gratuite e quindi non son costano e
quindi non possono essere cedute
gratuitamente a questo punto ci sono tre
strade la prima offrire contenuti in
maniera gratuita in cambio della
pubblicità ed è quello che è la radio ha
sempre fatto è che la televisione
a parte il canone diciamo nell'attesa di
stato ha sempre fatto la seconda
possibilità è far pagare i contenuti ma
si riesce a far pagare i contenuti in un
mondo dove l'informazione è così basta
solo se si hanno contenuti esclusivi e
originali cioè non uguale agli altri
perché se un contenuto a pagamento e
l'altro è gratis e e si equivalgono
andrò sempre su quello gratuito terzo
adottare modelli misti cioè dare una
parte dei contenuti gratuiti perché
commodity perché c'erano tutti e far
pagare dei contenuti più approfonditi
quindi il primo punto non può essere
grati
secondo punto la mobilità i cellulari i
cellulari e tablet
ce ne siamo resi conto tutte negli
ultimi due tre anni hanno creato un
nuovo mercato nuovo pubblico perché noi
quando siamo aspettare il tram quando
siamo in metropolitana quando siamo qui
e magari non ci interessa all intervento
e ci annoiamo apriamo le cellule a noi
guardiamo cosa è successo da qualche
parte
ora se questi sono diventati dei device
degli strumenti per veicolare
l'informazione
bisogna che i giornalisti si attrezzano
per fare dell'informazione adatta a
quelli a quegli strumenti è assurdo che
io sul cellulare debba vedermi la prima
parla il sito del corriere così come è
stato pensato per uno schermo di
computer enorme io devo avere delle
notizie veloci rapide di facile lettura
sull'ipad sul cellulare o su qualsiasi
altro strumento quindi cominciare a fare
un giornalismo con il linguaggio degli
strumenti su cui ormai la maggior parte
delle persone si informa perché sono
convinto che moltissime persone non
coppa più giornale ma guardano su
cellulare notizie sull'ipad
terzo punto le social news l'abbiamo
detto i giornalisti non sono più i
padroni esclusivi delle notizie
se perché è così la maggior parte delle
persone sta sui social media
e lì che dobbiamo portare le notizie
dobbiamo portarli in maniera ancora una
volta e con un linguaggio che sia quello
adatto a questi strumenti a freddo
perché sto prendendo troppo tempo la
credibilità è una cosa fondamentale
l'attendibilità del giornalista non è
più il duo un dono che deriva dalla
testata come è stato fino a dieci anni
fa o a 20 anni fa il giornalista oggi
deve guadagnarsi questa credibilità in
ogni istante in ogni attimo perché fuori
c'è un pubblico che lo segue che lo vede
e siccome nella rete c'è sempre qualcuno
che su quel fatto sa qualcosa più di te
è pronto a intervenire ea dire la sua
quindi sei come sotto esame in ogni
istante qualsiasi cosa tu scriva tu
faccia quindi la reputazione
una diverso modo di affrontare le cose
perché un tempo to scrivere un pezzo
bello brutto ma non sapevi mai che cosa
le persone pensavano o comunque le
persone non avevano una voce in capitolo
oggi con i commenti un lettore può
criticare il tuo pezzo può dirti dove
hai sbagliato e quindi è molto
importante riprendere con attenzione la
reputazione
ovviamente le metriche giornalismo è una
questione di qualità non solo di
quantità e quindi bisogna introdurre nei
sistemi digitali di misurazione del
valore del giornalismo l'elemento della
qualità infine il giornale può esistere
un giornale di carta posti internet ma
io credo che possa esistere almeno
ancora per qualche anno qualche decennio
me lo auguro
se abbandonerà l'idea che il giornale
debba dare le notizie che ormai tutti
noi abbiamo letto con altri mezzi
durante il giorno e comincerà a dare
spiegazioni
le cause e le conseguenze dei fatti e
non raccontare i fatti che già
conosciamo quindi il giornale del futuro
dovrà avere molta meno quantità e molta
più qualità dovranno essere più brevi
più selettivi più pensati per apportare
un elemento di originalità in un mondo
dove ormai si conoscono quasi tutte le
informazioni ecco io penso che se in
futuro cioè per l'informazione questo
futuro debba ripartire dall elemento
centrale il lettore il lettore è
cambiato non è più quello che era dieci
anni fa e allora o i giornalisti trovano
un modo per cambiare se stessi e il modo
con cui fanno giornalisti i giornalisti
oppure rischiano di perdere con la carta
anche il lettore che sarebbe un dramma
ben peggiore grazie